[Music]
ask questions like what happened before
the big bang
what is the nature of time and then you
get quantum physics what's the nature of
reality and then you get the life what
is life and then what is consciousness
you know all those things
which i love to think about you can't
think about those without coming up
against those same age-old questions
that for centuries were part of religion
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
open the pod bay doors now i am thrilled
to welcome to the into the impossible
podcast a legendary
cosmologist a physicist an author an
intellectual and a scholar who was my
last guest live in person
before the pandemic set in in january
2020 he was gracious enough to come to
ucsd and did an event
with one of the benford boys i always
mix up if it's greg or if it's james but
no mind we talked about whether or not
e.t is lurking in our cosmic backyard
and we had a great discussion about one
of paul's great books from at that time
it was a 10 year old book i believe and
that was about the eerie silence and
today he's back with a new book and it
is called what is eating not eating what
is eating the universe
and i want to understand
as we often want to be told not to do
paul the advice is often saying don't
judge a book by its cover but i want to
judge this book by its cover how did you
come up with the title and the cover
design which is actually
quasi three-dimensional i mean it
actually opens up it's it's quite
beautiful so tell us paul what what is
the origin of this very provocative and
uh whimsical title
uh well bran let me first say that i'm
just the author so i had no choice over
the cover
i thought it was quite a clever idea to
uh cut the holes in the in the jacket uh
to sort of expose the universe behind so
i i like it
but as far as the title is concerned
what's eating the universe so this book
i should say uh was my lockdown creation
i'd intended to write the book anyway
but the lockdown accelerated it wasn't
it wonderful we were all confined to
courses
with nothing much else to do and all the
foreign travel cancelled and so i
thought well i'll just smash on and
finish this book so it's come out six
months ahead of what it was supposed to
and it started out
really as a collection
of
chapters each of which
deals with some aspect of cosmology
and let me just
preface that by saying that i've lived
through what i call the golden age of
cosmology i've had a front row seat
during that time
i think cosmology moved from when i was
a student to be being a speculative
backwater of science to really a
mainstream precision sound so we can
measure so many things but like all
golden ages brought its successes but
also opened up lots of new questions and
mysteries and i wanted this to be both a
celebration of the amazing achievements
that have occurred during my career but
also
to show that for any young people
thinking of going into science and
fascinated by the universe there's still
plenty of things left to do and it's not
impossible that some of these
anomalies the things that don't quite
fit
will fundamentally transform our
understanding of the large-scale
structure of the universe and what's
eating the universe is one of the
chapters
we decided uh the
publisher and i decided that it was
probably a good title to give to the
book but it's just one of a number of
mysteries that are being discussed
and it really has to do with to be quite
specific a funny patch in the southern
hemisphere a cold patch in the sky
that the entire universe is bathed in
heat radiation the fading afterglow of
the big bang
and the extraordinary thing about this
fading afterglow is that it's uh it
shows us it's a like snapshot of the
universe in its very earliest stages and
it shows us that the universe was almost
totally pristine i was sort of flawless
perfect baby
but with one or two scars or blemishes
and one of these blemishes is uh this
patch in the southern hemisphere which
is uh cooler than the rest cooler than
it's supposed to be
and
one particular cosmologist laura mercini
halton had speculated that uh it's
almost as if
cosmic jams has taken a bite out of the
universe speculated it might be because
another universe has bumped into ours
and has left a scar
or might even be swallowing hours or um
there are other ways in which the
universe can be swallowed so that seemed
like you know a really fun topic to give
to the title of the book
and so that's that's really where it
came from
and it is a delightfully whimsical book
it's really a collection of essays in a
certain sense
uh that uh i found quite uh you know
bewitching and enticing to read it was
an easy fast read for me and i was
gratified to see even some data from the
bicep 2 experiment that i played a role
in way back when and i want to start
there because you have had such a such a
profound influence not just on me as a
as a physicist but on on all of physics
and cosmology you've interacted with and
created
some of the greatest
works that are pertinent more pertinent
than ever in addition to your outreach
but i want to start there with today's
news i don't know if you heard it it's
neutrino news and it comes out of the
micro boone experiment uh recording this
in late october 2021 i don't know when
this will be out
but as of today there is no evidence for
sterile neutrinos from the micro boone
experiment
and i wanted to to kind of get your take
on these things because there are
several anomalies that are described at
lovingly
intense levels of detail but popular
accessible to a popular audience as well
which is rare that you have a book that
appeals to experts like me and the leon
but anyway
what do you make of these proliferation
of hints of crises of of you know of
anomalies as stephen weinberg said once
physics thrives on crises luckily today
there aren't so many that was back in
1989 we have enough we're living in a
golden age of crises uh what do you make
of of this and in particular the lack of
finding um of this sterile neutrino uh
you know evidence or hint today
well i'm not up to date with the news
about the sterile neutrino but let me
first make a very general comment in
case people are wondering we've flipped
from talking about a big hole in the
universe to talking about the one of the
tiniest things we can imagine the the
great point about our understanding of
the universe is that it really combines
the very large and the very small and so
sometimes it said that the big bang was
the greatest particle physics experiment
ever conducted
and our understanding of how the
universe is shaped what it's made of and
what it's going to do
is in large part
dependent on our understanding of
quantum mechanics and particle physics
and the physics of the very small of
which neutrinos form apart and so when
you talk about you know crises and
anomalies uh they really come in these
two categories things like you know
funny patch in the sky uh doesn't seem
quite right and also things in the realm
of particle physics
and now let me just again
be quite general about particle physics
so something that we call the standard
model it's been around for some decades
and it's a sort of um
patch up job it's a halfway house at an
attempted unification of all the
fundamental particles and forces of
physics
and
in a way it's
part of the program that began two and a
half millennia ago in ancient greece the
idea that the universe is made of some
fundamental building blocks
and that everything that happens
is simply the rearrangement of these
building blocks and and that's all there
is
the the building blocks and the void
they called the building blocks atoms
but today we know the things we call
atoms today are not the fundamental
blocks but we can go down a few layers
and then we get a whole bunch of things
like you know quarks and leptons and
and you know bother to enumerate them
all except some of them have quixotic
names and and i
in the book say that many physicists
have their favorite particle of which
mine is the the graviton but but that's
by the by the point is uh that this is
not a totally disordered mishmash of
particles and forces there seems to be a
mathematical unity there
and over the uh well the decades really
there's been a sort of convergence in
the
in all these disparate things we used to
think when i was a student there were
particles being discovered
you know every week nobody knew what to
call them um nobody understood how they
fitted together we now understand that
the that there is a an underlying
mathematical scheme but
it's you know there's a way to go yet
and some of the things we
encounter and have encountered for a
while don't fit into that scheme don't
fit into the standard model
one of these for example is neutrino
mass so we we know of three types of
neutrinos that we're definite about um
and
they are now known to have
tiny masses
and the standard model of particle
physics has no mechanism to assign the
masses so we know there is some physics
beyond the standard model uh the other
area that
is i would say is now an anomaly is that
um there's a it's not a firm belief i
mean it's really a faith i think
among theoretical physicists that the
two great classes are particles fermions
and um
bosons these are the particles of matter
on the one hand and the particles that
convey the forces of nature on the other
hand that they
should somehow be combined together into
a single mathematical scheme and that
scheme was worked out years ago it's
called supersymmetry and when the large
hadron collider was built
in switzerland to make the higgs boson
famously did make it uh there was a
general expectation that in the lead-up
to making the higgs boson uh it would
also make supersymmetric partner
particles that is that for every boson
there would be a
corresponding lepton of every lepton
there would be a corresponding boson and
that at least one of these particles
would manifest itself well that hasn't
happened
and so what are we to make of that does
it mean that the the supersymmetry is
not a symmetry of nature after all
uh or does it mean that we need a bigger
and better uh accelerator in order to
access the energies of which these super
partners might uh might appear nobody
knows that but it clearly that you know
that is one flaw in uh in our
understanding there are others as well
uh having to do with the possibility of
new particles which are being uh
for which there are some suggested
suggestive evidence uh nothing uh
definitive um and um
uh
and just at a general
uh
despair would be overstating it but
frustration that the the force of nature
that we most notice which is gravitation
it's what keeps our false feet on the
ground
uh doesn't have a slick unification with
the other forces of nature
so it's like uh an add-on it's almost as
if you know god created the universe and
all these particles and three-folds of
nature and then as an afterthought
throwing gravitation but hadn't quite
figured out how to combine it with the
others and we and we haven't figured
that out although there's some some
famous candidate theories so there's a
lot still to be done and a lot of things
don't fit in
one other thing that i suppose i should
mention is an obvious i suppose anomaly
but you read about it so often it
doesn't seem very anomalous and that's
dark matter that we know
the stuff of which you and i are made
and the stars
are
atoms basically
is only a tiny fraction of all the
matter that is out there and
what is called dark matter well there
are plenty of theoretical candidates
what it might be
but so far nobody knows we can see its
effects from its gravitational pull
but again we would hope that something
like a dark matter particle
which would be very weakly interacting
be like neutrinos but much more massive
would show up at the large hadron
collider some some clue at least as to
what dark matter might be so far nothing
so we're left in the literally in the
dark about dark matter about neutrino
masses and any possible additional
neutrinos and
a host of other oddities
about particle physics as well as the
large-scale structure of the universe
some somehow it's all got to be fitted
together
and i want to make reference to a
spin-off from the book which describes
even just the question of if there's a
proliferation of particles and you know
the famous words of wolfgang paoli can
you know conceiver of the neutrino you
know who ordered that uh and then later
the the saying that the nobel prize
should go to the first person who
doesn't discover a new particle now
we've moved on from uh merely
conjecturing and discovering new
particles to actually invoking the
existence of new forces so we hear a lot
about fifth forces and so forth and you
even mentioned in the book the g minus
two anomaly uh et cetera and i thought
you know maybe we could get into uh to
to a discussion of whether or not there
are four forces five forces you say the
list of particles i have that i've
introduced in this chapter raises the
question of why
is there a deeper reason for the list to
be populated in just this way by just
those particles and just those masses
electrocharges and spins and is there
something magical about four or as you
said really three basic forces rather
than five or fifty or five hundred
um i was taught paul by uh by many
eminent uh scientists in my career that
you should never ask why as a scientist
you should only ask what how when
um you know etc but uh but you asked
this question i wanna ask it back to you
what do you mean by why is that a
legitimate uh question for legitimate
physicists such as yourself to even
countenance ask it
oh well of course you could ask what you
like and i
strongly encourage
uh that scientists should ask the why
question even if we know that in
coming up with explanations we're we're
really dealing with the how because uh
it why is of course a rather ill-defined
term but it very often carries the
connotation of on purpose you know what
why did you do that
and uh
and if we caught out doing something we
shouldn't then we come up with excuses
right or why can't i do that and the
parent always has to say because because
i said so that's right
but
but there is some uh a subtext to this
and it's one i've been involved with for
my entire career and the the older i get
the more i feel it's significant that we
and the human beings uh try to make
sense of the world we live in a universe
which is not just it appears a rag bag
of odds it ends it does appear to be a
sort of coherent scheme of things and
indeed you wouldn't embark on the
scientific enterprise in the first place
if you didn't feel that there was a sort
of rational and intelligible order
beneath the surface phenomena of nature
and to dig out that order this is a
non-trivial thing you don't just look
around you and say oh i can see this i
can see that i see how it all fits
together it's not apparent at all so
nobody would have ever discovered
neutrinos or the higgs boson just by
casual inspection of the world you never
know they even existed so we have these
arcane
procedures of you know building weird
machines and doing peculiar stuff to
matter that maybe has never been done
before and and writing funny symbols on
blackboards and bits of paper and sort
of figuring out how the world works and
it's been just spectacularly successful
had what three and a half centuries of
really doing much more than just
describing the world that's not what
theoretical physics does it just it
doesn't just give an account to the
world it explains the world it leads to
an understanding we
if you look at for example you could ask
here we go with the y question
um
why
are there electromagnetic waves you know
we know lighters and electromagnetic
waves so why are there wave-like
solutions of the equations uh well you
sit down you look at the equations you
you manipulate them you solve them and
out comes the familiar uh equation for a
wave and so that gives you an answer
then you look at that and you think aha
now i understand why there are
electromagnetic waves well in a sense
that's asking uh you know how is it that
they come about okay fair enough but you
see the point
about asking the why questions it leads
you to that aha moment that ah i've got
it now i see how it's put together and
we would like to believe i'm sure all of
us are driven by this passion to explain
the world um that there are reasons for
why things are as they are that there
would be you know three generations of
particles and
all of these other things that if we
work a bit harder there will be that aha
moment now it all makes sense
but of course there's only an act of
faith it may be that the universe
doesn't actually make sense or doesn't
make sense to a human being after all
what we call common sense and what we
arrive at as understanding is something
that has been selected by uh
evolution that we've evolved through
natural selection to survive in the
proverbial jungle and yet we're equipped
with this cognitive ability uh to not
just observe the world but to
understand it at this deeper level of
reality i consider that pretty
stupendous yeah and it may be we just
had a dream run uh that we've had a few
centuries where we've been really good
at this and we're going to soon hit a
brick wall and the whole enterprise will
grind to halt i really hope that isn't
the case i really do think we can go
further and that there is some some
underlying order that we're
not not quite getting that we're missing
at this stage and that's for the next
generation we need help to understand
what's going on and when we think about
you know kind of the the goals and the
teleological driven physics you know
oftentimes we are at a loss because we
want to connect you know the reasons as
you're saying for these phenomena with
with something that we can a comprehend
and maybe even be measure but i want to
ask you know you've had such an
illustrious career and i've never seen
you as a as a fad or you know
fashionable uh chaser as as uh
yeah as our friend sir roger penrose
calls you know fads and fantasies and
fallacies and physics uh past guests on
the show and i wanna i wanna ask you
though as a as a theorist you know
speaking to an experimentalist like me
how do you know when to take a hint from
an experimentalist seriously in other
words we come up with uh experiments to
test theories primarily sometimes we
discover things serendipitously like the
uh the cmb ball sitting behind me was
discovered serendipitously in 1965 as
you talk about and but
nevertheless most of what we do is
driven by some teleological purpose that
uh physicists such as yourself and other
colleagues
have come up with ideas for how the
universe how that pattern got there and
we set out to design tests to unravel
perhaps the relic radiation in the form
of gravitational waves to maybe indicate
the presence of a hyperluminal expansion
called inflation we'll get into
inflation and your contributions to it
in a minute
but
what is it that allows you to have the
taste the good taste and the good sense
that you have as i hope to instill in my
students have good taste to know which
theories to investigate how do you know
when to to risk your credibility on
something like you know the g minus two
or recently there was a um there was a
hint in my field of cosmic birefringence
and polarization rotation at the 2.5
sigma level last week there was a hint
from the large hadron collider beauty
experiment lhc lowercase b uh we'll be
talking with harry cliff about that soon
and uh and that was like a 1.5 sigma
um you know but and yet when bicep came
out there were 700 papers you know
explaining how we could have gotten such
a large tensor to scalar ratio none by
you i should point out but anyway paul
can you explain uh your rubric is there
a rubric that an eminent person such as
yourself would use to delineate what is
worth my you know spending or wasting um
a considerable amount of my most
precious resource my time on a new
experimental hint
right well there's a pompous answer to
that and it's the application of bayes
rule uh of course
so bayes rule tells you you have to
assign some
prior probability that a particular
theory or idea
is going to be correct and then you
update it in the light of the experiment
and uh and i'll give you a very simple
example that i'm often involved in
that
you have we discovered life on mars
so you know wouldn't that be great
and i'm often asked you know there's
some little hint of evidence does that
mean there's life on mars uh and i say
well you know if you do base rule uh in
my view uh the because earth and mars
trade rocks all the time they could
trade microbes and so
i think it's almost inevitable that
there will be life on mars if only
because he got there from earth
but if you think that life arose
independently on earth and mars well the
probability of life arising de novo from
a mishmash of chemicals could be
exceedingly small in which case you'd
need very strong evidence
that you had found life on mars so so
that's part of it
in practice of course unlike you i have
the luxury of being able to do
you know cancer biology in the morning
cosmology
in the afternoon and quantum physics in
in the evening and um my research moves
at the speed of thought
and i don't need to apply for a large
research grant and build equipment and
you know hire people to uh
service the lab and all that sort of
stuff and so
that makes it uh very easy to be agile
but in terms of um
making decisions uh so there's a large
element of luck i have to say so i
worked um in i
let me just give you a little bit of you
know you can tell
how old i am because you know i keep
reminiscing about the glory days of the
past but it it actually is significant
in answering your question because um i
went to cambridge university as a
postdoc of fred hoyle the cosmologist in
1970 and uh
you know the lads down the corridor and
there was only one female
a postdoc at that time included um
stephen hawking and uh martin reece and
jim hartle and you know the sort of roll
call of now the great and the good uh
but they were just um just my colleagues
uh and working on various things and
this is relevant to answering your
question in two ways uh because one is
that martin reese
was strongly influential on me
for the reason that he occupies that
sort of intermediate position between
theory and in astronomy's case it's more
observation than experiment
and i would always figure can i take
this seriously uh you know what about
that point of view
and i would go to him and and i would
feel that if he said it's okay take it
seriously or if he said don't take it
seriously that that was very good but so
having that those people who can act as
a bridge between
the
the the hard end of the science and of
the experiment and observation and the
sort of airy fairy theory those people
are extremely useful
uh and i i'm really grateful that he
remains a good friend of mine all these
years on yeah and then the other person
stephen hawking that is a curious thing
because
at that time
i was uh interested
for my phd
i
uh worked on something called the
wheeler feinman theory of
electrodynamics so this is an attempt to
explain
um why
we see only [ __ ] electromagnetic
radiation roughly speaking why
radio waves are received after they're
sent and not before even though the
fundamental equations of
electromagnetism are time symmetric and
fred hoyle who i went to work with had
connected that through this wheeler
feynman theory of electrodynamics which
is time symmetric has advanced and
[ __ ] waves and connected it up with
cosmology and the structure of the
universe and he thought that only in the
steady state theory would you get
[ __ ] electromagnetic waves turned
out that wasn't true but that's not the
point the point is that
i that's what i worked on for my phd and
it connected the large and the small i
thought it was wonderful that something
that
told us about
radio emissions from the local station
would connect to the structure of the
universe same same with max principle i
was always fascinated
so then um towards the end of my phd
which is in the late 1960s
i noticed a number of people working on
a very obscure backwater of science
which was
if you apply quantum physics in
particular
quantum field theory um in an expanding
universe it looked like particles got
created so i thought well is that how
all the matter came to the universe in
the big bang you know was it just
some sort of
quantum vacuum uh disturbance something
like that uh that turns out that wasn't
the case but i was sort of intrigued but
the
the effects seemed to be so tiny
that it didn't look like anyone else
would be interested and so i i worked on
you know particle creation and expanding
universes famous paper by leonard parker
at that time
and and also applying quantum physics to
black holes i thought you know there
might be some
some value in that but it all seemed
incredibly theoretical and this was
totally transformed when stephen hawking
then in 1974 came up with his
idea that black holes are not black but
glow with heat radiation by applying
quantum physics to it um and that was
something that sort of threw me at the
time because i thought well i've been
thinking about this for a little while
um i'd never discussed that with stephen
but we had talked a little bit about
the particle creation and expanding
universes um but really this sort of
came out of the blue
and i thought well how can it be the
case because the black hole you know the
schwarzschild solution of a black hole
is time symmetric how can there be a
flux of radiation because i was already
working on my book the physics of time
asymmetry the arrow of time so it seemed
to sort of fly in the face of that and
it took me a few weeks of
head scratching before i could guilt
that aha but now i now i see what's
going on here that there is that you
break the time
uh symmetry of the system with the
collapse of the star you see so even
though a black hole might have been
around for billions of years and is
glowing
that glow
reflects the disruption to the quantum
vacuum billions of years ago it's an
extraordinary thing that it's like the
fading grin of the cheshire cat living
on after all that time took a while to
figure that out um
but
you see because i'm sort of in on the
ground floor of that and then worked i
went to king's college in london to the
mathematics department had a lot of good
students and post-docs and we worked on
going beyond what lena parker had done
and trying to work out
you know the the big problem
you can talk in quantum mechanics you
can use particle language people do they
talk about particles being created from
the vacuum and all that sort of stuff
but if you're interested in gravitation
you don't want particles what you want
is
this thing called the stress energy
momentum tensor think energy really that
you know mass gravitates energy's a form
of mass it's more complicated than that
in einstein's general theory of
relativity it's the whole stress energy
momentum tensor you need and when you
work that out in quantum physics you
find you get the unhappy answer of
infinity um
and
the reason for that is just because even
in a vacuum
that
there's a sort of irreducible level of
quantum energy which is flitting around
and when you turn it all up it's it's
actually divergence infinite so we had
to develop some techniques for taming
that for getting sensible finite results
and again it looked to us in the
mid 70s late 70s and it's very much
theoretical exercise we're largely
thinking about how do you explain how
black holes lose mass because negative
energy flows in as we found um but also
you know applying it to the expanding
universe just
you know completing the program that
leona parker begun and it was really
more
i still thought it was a backwater more
of a sort of elegant uh enterprise than
anything that would have application and
then bang in the 1980s along came the
inflationary scenario of the early
university it left in size by an
enormous factor in the first split
second a a phase of exponential
expansion and we've done all that stuff
we've looked at the quantum vacuum and
expanding exponentially expanding space
time
sort of ready with the answer um and so
it i was very fortunate that these
things turned out to to find application
that and to be perfectly honest um by
the time all this was settling down in
the mid 80s and everyone was dashing off
into string theory and i thought about
that and my colleague seemed obsessed
with it and i really didn't want to go
down that path
and then i began to turn my attention to
other topics i thought well i'm sort of
bored
10-15 years doing quantum fields in
curved space you know i i started
getting interested in the origin of life
and and i'm matt massey in passing and
i'm talking a lot here but in passing
that was also martin reed so i have to
thank for that because in 1983
he held a meeting in cambridge called
from mata to life and of course i've
read schrodinger's little book about
what is life uh and viewed through the
eyes of a physicist you know it looks
like magic
and uh
and after that conference i thought well
you know it's even more like magic than
i thought but but i don't believe in
magic so there have to be mechanisms we
don't understand the physics of living
matter is something that needs a lot
more work and a lot more thought and
that became a sort of hobby uh that uh
fast forward to now it's very much
dominating my thoughts so i've been able
to sort of move across all across the
map
uh and maybe that's been to my
disadvantage maybe if i stayed in some
narrow area and just kept plugging away
and re-emphasizing contributions and so
on um you know i might have i might have
had greater glory if that's what we're
after i don't know what we're after as
practicing scientists but but you know
i'm really pleased to have such diverse
interests and to be able to to to move
across these these different subjects
and disciplines so could could you
clarify for for us you know the rubric
that one might apply at least deriving
from what you just said or distilling it
is really when based on kind of
discursive curiosity it seems to me
that you're just relentlessly curious
and i always say that you know passion
is kind of like a spark it's important
to ignite you know a rocket or something
but the real fuel is curiosity and it
seems like the thing that characterizes
you said at the beginning of this of
this answer uh was you know curiosity
everything from cancer to the cosmos uh
and everything in between and uh but but
there's always a through line which i
think
i i see in you a reluctance to work on i
wouldn't say trivial in the sense of uh
boring or unimportant but um you you
have done work that's foundational and
fundamental as you just mentioned um
but you like to take on the very grand
and you're not averse to talking about
big picture topics in philosophy and
even theology which we'll get into
not that you're the only physicist i
mean many many from einstein galileo
newton etc have gotten into these but
you know from the from the standpoint of
a of a you know of a practicing work a
day theorist uh at some level it's
important to to go deep and sometimes
you have to go abroad and i guess the
question is uh are you unique is it is
is there something to be learned from
paul davies or is it just that you have
this gift this you know discursive
curiosity as i called it um or are there
ways to uh for my audience and people
that might be young aspiring theoretical
or experimental physicists is there a
tool is there a technique to find the
nugget of uh of the most interesting
kernel uh uh that that one could pursue
or is it sometimes just a matter of
serendipity or luck well as i've
mentioned there is an element of life
but there are certain guiding
principles um one of these is your
curiosity is of course important i'm
very tolerant of pretty way out ideas
and you can be tolerant but skeptical
it's really important you say well i
don't think this is actually right um
but you know tell tell me how you think
it is and uh you know i will i will pay
some attention so that's one thing the
other thing is for young people
uh it and it's i think it's probably
worse now than when i was uh uh
embarking on my career uh is uh that if
you sort of go off into the weeds and
and don't establish a reputation in some
sort of mainstream discipline it's it's
actually very hard to build a career and
i i benefit very greatly from my
collaboration here at arizona state
university with sarah walker
and sarah i could tell i knew her as a
phd student
i could tell she shared my passion for
you know all of these wonderful
questions and she came on a
nasa astrobiology postdoc to work with
me and we wanted to solve the problem of
life's origin and we're still working on
that um
but the advice i gave her and i think
it's very sound and it's worked very
well in her case is that you know devote
about half of your time to sort of just
good solid contributions at a technical
level i mean in her case it's all theory
at a technical level uh to you know some
sort of mainstream topic that will get
the papers will be published people pay
attention and so on then the other half
you can sort of go off into this um you
know never neverland uh of these these
really big questions and she's she's
done that very well i i signed her 10
years ago a younger version of myself
at that age i recognized you know that
sort of passion to uh to really get to
grips with things but
it's not just a matter of
well you follow up somebody else's ideas
we need new ideas and she's been very
good at saying we're thinking about this
all the wrong way and we should this is
the concept we need or we should try
this out or try that way of looking at
it um and and so that would be my advice
to any dr
listening to these words uh that they
you know don't neglect your sort of
mainstream stuff and and for me that
that worked well the other thing is
uh of course in any sort of university
setting
there is a small match of students
they're around they're important
i love them
they have to be taught
and so
some attention needs to be given to just
those sort of housekeeping issues giving
good inspiring lectures uh well put
together
on all the other sort of university
administration things so that aspect of
one's career can't be neglected
very few scientists who have really made
it big time by sort of going off and
living lives as hermits uh and doing
groundbreaking work you're part of the
community you've got to play by the
community rules
very good uh i very much appreciate that
and i agree about sarah she's an
inspiration to me and she's
just so tremendously energetic and um
and thoughtful and considerate
and like you as you say uh she's well
she's influencing you so i i don't think
it's patronizing in any way but she is
only interested in the biggest picture
topics and i really respect that and
i've had her colleague on lee cronin
from glasgow and i hope to have sarah on
as well
i want to talk about some of the deep
dives that we got into in this book and
you have just uh again you know i'm
sorry to just keep praising you with
high praise not faint praise but strong
praise but um you have a true gift that
explaining very very abstract concepts
like cp violation uh things in my
audience because they're the brilliant
most brilliant audience in the known
universe
have seen and encountered and even had
great great uh conversations about i
want to talk about uh these departures
from you know again anomalies that don't
seem to make sense and here's a line of
logic that i've been using and maybe you
can disabuse me of it
but the fact that the laws of nature
aren't perfectly symmetric
and in a certain sense we're trying to
enforce things like super symmetry uh
and and so forth which is today not
really panned out according to the
rubric you outlined uh you know two or
three questions ago we should apply
baze's rule and so i wonder is it a
fool's errand to try to uh impose kind
of this need for beauty symmetry
parsimony economy on the laws of nature
when we know that they're actually in
violation of it on a regular basis and
in fact you know if i had a bet on it i
might not even suspect that lorentz
invariance holds over the entirety of
the universe so what do you make of this
desire to to i mean if an alien knew the
answer and was looking at our theories
and say why are you looking for
something so symmetric we know the
universe isn't symmetric and so why are
you trying to cram all these theories
into one you know god equation which
we'll get to in a bit do you think that
that's a fool's errand do you think
that's a more of a projection of
physicists as as human beings rather
than as you know purely scientific
entities or do you think there's
something to be gained for looking for
symmetry beauty and parsimony
well that's that's a very important
question
and it's certainly true uh that over the
past uh two or three hundred years uh
the application of occam's razor has
really manifested itself by uh looking
for symmetries uh it's just as uh
sometimes as simplifying features in a
in an approximation
and
there's always this danger that
something that seems to
work so well in so many ways we will
take
a sort of founding principle of the
nature of reality
but it's clear that if the the universe
was symmetric in all its aspects that we
wouldn't be here that you have to break
symmetries to get structure
and um the one that of course most
intrigued me because it goes right back
to my phd thesis was the time reversal
symmetry uh breaking
uh and it's it's again a case of well
who needs that yeah
we
we can uh break the symmetry of the
world by setting the universe up in
an orderly state and letting the second
order of thermodynamics do the rest wait
you know why do we need to break uh
to have t violation down at the particle
physics level and nobody's really ever
connected those two up nobody has ever
said well uh t violation in particle
physics explains the ordered nature of
the universe just after the big bang so
some people have dabbled around in that
but uh it so remains one of these sort
of oddities so why is it there and it
could just be again that we've had a
dream run of success um
the we're in a similar situation i think
with linearity
so uh the the great advances in physics
in the 19th century stemmed in large
part from the fact that many everyday
phenomena
are approximately linear and you can
go a long way
using
linear differential equations and
free analysis those sorts of things
and so that works well for you know heat
conduction and uh
and wave motion and uh you know a whole
bunch of things that are important but
uh in the last uh 50 years or so the
importance of non-linear phenomena have
become very
prominent and in particular chaos theory
and
various forms of complexity which have
become popular but difficult to study
because they're not tractable by these
simple scientific
methods simple equations um and so that
raises the interesting question have we
just cherry-picked the stuff that we're
good at
and that we say physics is amazing
explained all these things look um
uh we we know the secrets of the
universe and we've got all these
equations um but we're just defining
success in terms of this rather small
subset of phenomena
we're surrounded by all sorts of things
we really don't understand you know
including things like turbulence
which
it so boils down to is it a bottle half
full or half 20 and just quite how much
longer we can uh
have success with essentially 19th
century
methods is an interesting thought you
know are we are we getting to the point
where we simply can't do that i don't uh
i mentioned that i've become sort of
obsessed with life and the physics of
living matter and so on i don't think
traditional laws of physics
linear or otherwise are a good fit to
the nature of life um
that that to understand life we need to
organize data about the world in a
completely different way from uh
underlying laws and initial and boundary
conditions so you can try doing that but
you don't get very far so there must be
another way of doing
science
which
which we need to come up with some
people think this is also true in
cosmology that because
if you think there's only one universe
and that
we can argue about that uh but if there
is only one what does it mean to say we
apply the laws of physics to the
universe because if there's only one of
it the whole idea of laws is that
there's supposed to be
um
a a whole class of
similar systems and you can have
different initial conditions and so on
uh there's only one universe uh can we
meaningfully apply laws to it uh or do
does it need some other way
of of attack so um you know i think we
might be approaching the point where we
need some radically new thinking not
just about the particular equations that
we use
but the at a deeper level the way we
organize our facts about the world
uh maybe after
three or four hundred years uh we need a
different way of thinking about it
yeah i wanted to move into that subject
perhaps and that will lead us into a
discussion of the laws of
of nature in a universe that is a set of
elements within the multiverse and you
talk a lot in the book about you know
historical approach to our understanding
of the cosmos and and even uh and even
the great you know debates of previous
centuries and even of this current
century and i would say that you know
one of the most uh prominent among them
is of course the existence of the
multiverse and the concomitant
conjecture of a string landscape perhaps
these are fascinating these are very
delightful to consider and to
contemplate
until you start to think you know are
people taking this really seriously
and
you of course have a very famous uh
article that was in the new york times
and we'll talk about that when we talk
about uh god but uh but but specifically
uh relating to the multiverse which is a
an allied outcome
of most theories of inflation in other
words the the theory of uh uh that the
ex that there must be an infinity or at
least a very large number of universes
uh as you say in order to explain the uh
sign to the uns the properties of the
features of the universe we do see is
just as ad hoc as invoking an unseen
creator the multiverse theory may be
dressed up in scientific language but in
essence it requires the same leap of
faith
and so i want to get into that
this statement about faith and god and
so forth but first i want to take a step
back on a personal level
you made fundamental contributions to
the theory of inflation which now comes
with this you know ad hoc uh edition of
the multiverse um first can you explain
uh this foundational discovery that you
and um and bunch i forget what bunch his
name first name is but
timothy timothy bunch
the bunch davies vacuum state what is
that
how did you come upon it and what does
it have to do with inflation
right so i i touched on this a little
bit earlier
in two ways uh
one is that we wanted uh in the late
1970s to try to understand the quantum
vacuum uh in the presence of a
gravitational field and lena parker had
blazed the trail by looking at particle
creation and expanding universes but
there were a lot of
unclear aspects at that time we didn't
quite know how to think about a lot of
these things and the mathematical
techniques uh to regularize as we say
the stress energy momentum tension
hadn't really been worked out
a lot of people were working on that and
that got hammered out in the 1970s
but as i mentioned earlier
that
for young people it's great for them to
have
dreamy thoughts about uh big questions
but they also have to have some solid
accomplishments and the one burden
upon
anybody who has a student is you've got
to give them something uh that is not
only interesting but that they can work
out
and so tim needed his phd we needed to
find a system and a type of universe and
a type of quantum field where the
equations can be solved and tim would
get his degree
um and uh
what appealed to us uh was to sit a
space now let me just say this
interspace is a space that doubles in
size in a fixed time so it's
exponentially expanding was suggested by
villain de sitter in i think 1917 you
know pretty early on just after
einstein's general theory of relativity
um and it was a sort of toy model and
the extraordinary thing about the city
space is it's got the same number of
symmetries here we go again as ordinary
minkowski space flat spacetime
and so the equations of quantum physics
are just as easy to solve in the situ
space as they would be in you know in
the lab
um
having said that just as easy to solve
the solutions
uh are less familiar functions but the
the technique for solving it is uh just
as easy so um tim worked through all of
that and
julie got his phd
and uh we didn't know at that time that
the city space would play such a
prominent role uh we
it
uh pretty clear from the astronomical
evidence that we weren't living in this
into space it looked like the universe
was decelerating
and so two things then happened over
some decades first is
that inflation came along and inflation
means a phase of exponential expansion
extremely rapid in the first split
second of the universe and that was
posited by andre linde alex folenkin and
others in the early 1980s as a way of
explaining why the universe looks as i
said early like the you know the perfect
baby
so smooth and unblemished and
uniform
that nicely explains it and so it was an
attempt to get around
that mystery
but of course it was precisely this
exponential expansion that we had worked
on and we had these equations ready for
and
if you believe
uh because the
the e folding time for this
exponential expansion is uh is
stupendously small 10 to the minus 34
cents or something quantum effects are
going to be all important and so here
here we are with quantum effects and
expanding universe when inflation came
to an end uh because it you know has has
ended
and uh morphed into a traditional
decelerating slow expansion when that
happened uh the quantum fluctuations
during that
inflationary phase got sort of frozen in
and writ large and written in the sky
imprinted in the pattern in the
background the cosmic microwave
background radiation it's sort of up
there for everyone to see
there if you believe this those are
quantum fluctuations uh in the sky but
it's a snapshot of them they're not
fluctuating anymore
and
so that that's really how that came to
exist then the other the other thing
that happened of course
uh is that in the late 1990s astronomers
discovered that maybe the universe isn't
decelerating after all but it's actually
the expansion rate speeding up on that
we're now
embarking on another phase of
exponential expansion but now with uh
any folding time of you know billions of
years and not a
tiny fraction of a second uh so suddenly
you know the sitter space which was a
curiosity in the 70s turns out to have
at least two applications to modern
physics so that that's how i came to be
involved
and nowadays we hear a lot or at least
we did up until 2018 when sadly your
friend and colleague uh
stephen hawking passed away we heard a
lot about these bets involving black
holes and information and you talk a
little bit about the information paradox
i always
don't like to reveal all the contents of
the book because i want everybody to buy
a copy of it in both hard copy and in
digital media formats as i have
but i want to uh go back to that because
as i understand it uh steven would
concede all these bets and as uh as sir
roger penrose said once to me you know
the good thing about bet making a bet
with stephen is that uh you could you
could always be on his side no matter
which side you chose
but stephen would concede these bets for
example by conjecturing as juan
maldasena has done that you could solve
the black hole uh information loss
paradox and you could do so but you
could only do so in anti-de-sitter space
uh as far as i know uh we don't live in
anti-sitter space so
why do why did he concede these bets on
the basis of something that not only is
falsifiable but was false is falsified
why would you think that he would
concede such things was it merely for
attention i hope not but um how how do
you reconcile this fascination with all
these things like you know extra
dimensions and so forth and anti-sitter
space when we have zero evidence and
maybe contradictory evidence to those
claims
well first of all um you know stephen
and the bet so he was very fond of doing
u-turns and uh and i loved him for it um
the the one that i was most involved in
myself
is uh when
uh
for a time he thought that if the
universe recontracts the arrow of time
would be reversed and seeing as i'd uh
written a phd thesis on that i thought
oh not that again
because uh
sometimes uh this idea that we we live
in a cyclic universe cycle in time the
groundhog day type universe uh so it's
referred to in uh
by anthropologists it's the myth of the
eternal return and and so i was fond of
saying oh the eternal return has made
another return
um and
i the number of scientists who who got
caught up on this so the first i knew
was tommy gold
and then john wheeler who would
sometimes talk about the turning of the
tide uh wonderful metaphor a typical
wheeler um
and uh
then uh you know along came stephen
saying uh that this might be the case uh
and then uh maragama and and jim hartle
and you know this is an idea that won't
go away
but i i have um
not just theoretical reasons for
objecting to it i think um
there are observational uh reasons why
we shouldn't take it too seriously but
in that particular case stephen uh did
retract i was there
at the retraction it was in
spain a conference there and
he gave a lecture entitled my greatest
mistake um
echoing einstein whose
rejection of the co of the cosmo
whose acceptance of the cosmological
constant was his greatest
mistake and so says
steven uh flipped around on that i'm not
sure that anybody i didn't take the bet
didn't think to place a bet
on that one um but the black coming to
the black hole uh case and that
was a long-standing bet and
and it was always a mystery you see uh
way back in the 70s that okay black
holes glow with heat
how does the energy get out of the black
hole because nothing's supposed to come
out of a black hole that seemed a bit
strange and that's something i've
already alluded to that my colleagues
and i and i must thank
um
larry ford and
stephen fulling and bill andrew
uh and
and others who
helped
work out the stress energy momentum
tense around a black hole and we showed
that the
uh what happens is you have a flux of
negative energy
flowing into the black hole not positive
energy coming out
and
there's negative energy around all the
time what it means is uh that if you
take the energy of the quantum vacuum in
just sort of ordinary vacuum in
in the lab or something like that if you
can contrive a state of affairs where
the energy is less than that
then we would call that negative energy
and a very well-known example is the
casimir effect you have a couple of
mirrors facing each other and the uh
energy of the vacuum between those
mirrors is a little bit less than what
it would be if the mirrors weren't there
so that idea is not so bad um gravity
can produce a negative energies so the
gravity of the earth produces a cloud of
negative energy around it it's it's tiny
um but around a black hole it's really
quite big and
is it semantic in that you know we if we
called it positive we'd be asking why is
there positive energy flowing into a
black hole or is it you know ben
franklin you know called the charge
carrier and it was a negative charge
carrier and and uh the electron um and
and that com is it is it semantic or is
there something truly you know
fundamental about the aspect of it being
negative as opposed to positive right
there is so when we were in high school
we were told well the zero of energy is
arbitrary and uh it's energy differences
only that you can measure and that's
true until you come to gravitation uh
and if what you say is well energy
gravitates then that's a physical effect
and you can say will this particular
state
uh exert a gravity bend space-time
basically so if you define flat space
time to not be not bent then that the
quantum vacuum in flat space time has
got to be defined as zero energy i think
that's a very reasonable thing so
anything that is less than that we will
call negative energy and you can uh
gravitational fields can uh make it
negative or positive so it has both of
those effects around a black hole it's
negative it flows in and it pays for the
hawking radiation and so that was a
fairly uh simple one
but then there was this uh this other
one uh well you know what happens to the
information that falls down a black hole
the stuff that falls in
if you have a star or if you have a
black hole there and you throw in
the famous example throw in some
encyclopedias you know what happens to
all that information
uh
where the feeling was in the 70s it's
swallowed up forever it's never going to
come back
and that information is simply lost uh
down the black hole that didn't seem so
shocking because hawking and penrose and
others
told us that there were singularities
inside the black hole and a singularity
is a an edge of space time boundary uh
so if information hit that boundary it
would cease to exist at least in our
space time gone that's it didn't seem so
shocking but this didn't sit well with
people from a particle physics
background and now string theory
background that they don't like the idea
of
gravitation
space-time structure calling the shots
they want quantum mechanics to call the
shots they want that to be the founding
set of principles that govern the
universe and quantum mechanics has a
simple theorem
that information
can't be created or destroyed defined in
a certain way
and
you know what we were going to do about
that well um a lot of people at the time
thought and i think they still do that
black holes simply violate that
quantum principle
but
stephen towards the end of his career
decided to do one of his u-turns
and having said well it was violated and
said well maybe there is a way for it to
get out but the problem here
is that
when you you look at this as a technical
challenge you want to solve
the back reaction of
a quantum field on a black hole and see
how it shrinks and what happens what his
end state might be
well the simple answer is we don't have
a good theory of quantum gravitation
that can handle that very dense final
state would it be singular will it be
something else what will happen to it
when the black hole evaporates we don't
know how to do those calculations but we
do know from the work of don page
that you hit a problem uh long before
the black hole shrinks down to a plank
size or something like that
you you hit a problem about
the
the head count of all the bits of
information
and so
there is something we don't fully
understand
and the mathematical models that people
have appealed to to say well the
information gets out by this or that
mechanism are all extremely idealized
and
totally unrealistic cases
which
which have got a great deal of appeal
because people can manipulate the
equations i think this is still one of
the the great unsolved problems of
theoretical physics and it's one of the
things i alluded to in the book is we
need the next generation of of young
people to
tackle that
and uh if we also look at the
concomitant you know realization or most
wonderful realization of his life
according to albert einstein was that a
freely falling observer would experience
no gravitational field
um the corollary that you and bill unruh
and and maybe it was paige i forget who
came up with was that uh you could
actually detect acceleration
in the universe via an equivalent to the
hawking radiation effect i wonder if we
can talk a little bit about that i've
developed a great interest nowadays in
thinking about
the possibility that perhaps the
universe doesn't respect lorenzen
variants and why that shouldn't be
thought of as so sacrosanct without some
uh further degree of evidence it's a
nice shortcut a hack
you know and it certainly seems to hold
locally but as we know things that hold
locally don't often hold globally
so as einstein you know called this uh
the happiest thought of his life
and i by the way i think that that is a
reason that we should never fear
artificially intelligent physicists
because i don't know first of all if an
artificial intelligence could experience
happiness
and therefore come up with the the
strong equivalence print or the
equivalence principle but i also don't
know if it uh could experience uh you
know what free fall really would mean
because it's sort of a visceral
sensation attached to a body so
i could probably debate that with noam
chomsky again but i want to ask you um
it's it's sort of taken for granted that
uh that
motion is relative since the time of
galileo and the first relativistic uh
you know discovery that you talk about
in eating the universe what's eating the
universe but that acceleration could be
absolute can you explain and walk us
through that logic how can velocity be
strictly
uh you know uh the strictly
not not uh strictly relative but
acceleration could be absolute how could
those two after all isn't one just a
time derivative of the other
well i touched on this a little bit
earlier when i talked about max
principle and so it really goes right
back to the
founding fathers of modern physics
galileo newton leibniz descartes and
others about the nature of motion and i
i think
everybody came to accept that
linear motion or unaccelerated motion is
purely relative that uh there's you
can't sit in empty space and measure
your speed relative to space itself
um but
um acceleration seems quite different
because you feel it uh and the
example i give in the book you're flying
uh
at some altitude uh at a steady rate and
you fall asleep
as i often do on takeoff
can't tell if you're static on the
ground or whether you're actually
500 miles an hour in the air i do that
too but i'm a pilot so it's a little
more difficult right right i don't fall
asleep then um but um
but you know if you hit turbulence you
know immediately uh you can feel it and
so
for newton uh something like rotation uh
he regarded as absolute the earth bulges
at the equator and he uh felt that that
would be true even in an empty universe
but there's a long alternative tradition
which says
now even rotation and acceleration more
generally has to be gauged against the
distant matter in the universe after all
the world goes round it bulges at the
equator and we look up at the sky and
the stars are going around and so we can
tell the earth is spinning by looking at
the stars but we can also tell it's
spinning by measuring how
wide it is around the waist um and so
these are obviously connected through
newton's equations but this idea that
maybe even accelerated motion is
relative to this matter in the universe
uh
continues and it went uh well lance mach
gave us the famous mach numbers um
believed that there was a way of somehow
incorporating the local
technical terms compass of inertia but i
mean basically these forces like
centrifugal falls
could be attributed to the distant
matter in the universe and i mentioned
about my work in my phd the wheel of
hymen theory of electrodynamics which
has
it's a time symmetric thing where
radiation goes out into the universe but
advanced radiation comes back at you and
you're coupling
what's happening in the radio station to
what's happening in the distant matter
max principle is a similar sort of thing
uh if you can make it work it's a way of
connecting local physics to the to the
stars you know to put it romantically
the trouble is nobody's really been able
to make it work terribly well einstein
was a great fan of it hoped it would be
there in his general theory of
relativity but it's not there's
something called the care solution
of rotating black holes
and it's uh
empty space outside of of this black
hole and so there's no other matter and
yet the cursed solution uh has uh if you
put a test particle and you can it does
you can measure the rotation of this
spinning black hole
so this is unfinished business but i
don't know if you want me to connect it
to the story of accelerating
i would i would i would like to know how
could we actually measure our absolute
acceleration using the effect that you
and colleagues discover well well you
see the the
we were all brought up on this idea that
gravitation and acceleration were the
same um
which is of course as you say debatable
but it i didn't need to think too much
about it so when stephen hawking uh
announced his black hole result and i
thought how can that be i'm a bit
skeptical can i think and i don't wasn't
sure i understood the calculation um
that can i think of a simpler example uh
then i thought well you know what about
uniform acceleration and i was already
familiar with rindler's
textbook on uniformly accelerated
observers and you have a horizon there
just like it's a black hole horizon and
i knew of the work of stephen fulling
who then became a closest colleague of
mine
in which he looked at quantum fields in
in the rinder coordinate system
and i thought well i just need some sort
of simple argument that ties all this
together that would suggest that an
accelerating observer would basically
see hawking radiation in the same way
and uh and i produced them and published
that i didn't think uh anybody would pay
too much attention at a funny little
post script and here's a lesson for
students um i also thought i knew of
course from uh
from
simple enough uh physics that the sitter
space uh would be a have a similar
coordinate system and there would be a
temperature at the city space and i
remember sitting there in those days i
didn't even have an office didn't have a
desk i was sitting at my wife's dressing
table
and i thought well yes okay so i can
work out temperature space what is it
well what do i put in for the rate for
the hubble constant and i put in uh you
know the currently measured value and
now came the temperature i don't know 10
to the minus 30 degrees or something
although well no one be interested in
that i won't bother to mention it
so i wrote the paper and left out the
sitter space beard and uh and then the
the next year bill unruh uh wrote
sort of discovered the same effect by a
different argument involving a model of
a somewhat cumbersome model in those
days of
an accelerated detector that would go
click click click uh and then bryce
dewitt did a very nice job uh producing
a you know more usable model of an
accelerating detector um and you know
the rest is history as they say this
turned out to be
it it's still unclear to me whether
anybody has experimentally uh
verified this acceleration effect um
from time to time i get papers and
claims that this is sort of done either
directly or indirectly that the numbers
are very small you need a very very high
acceleration
to have a detectable
you know one degree or something um
but uh but i think we're sort of we're
beginning to see hints hints of it
anyway so that that's how i came into it
um looking looking back on it it didn't
seem any big deal at the time
but but some people think it's important
denis shiama i might say who was the uh
phd thesis advisor of hawking and rose
and
many other uh very martin reeds as well
yeah um uh he uh he was very fond of
this um and he thought this was was very
significant that this acceleration
effect uh really uh told us something
very deep about the nature of the
universe
and and i think that dream lives on but
you know we're several decades on from
this work in the centers and uh not sure
how much more progress we've made
yeah and that's somewhat delightful in
some ways but i think these things
really elicit
the
uh the biggest picture questions that
human beings might be capable
of answering or asking at least maybe
not answering but at least
asking them and i wanted to segue that
into
a talk about god if you'll indulge me
with some forbearance uh you and i have
talked
in person when i visited you and and
colleagues at arizona state university
uh where you have been uh for many years
and continue to contribute in public
fora and in uh and in research and
education as well in such a such a
monumental fashion but we we chatted on
a walk about this notion of of life as
sort of information and i wonder if you
know you are familiar with this famous
monograph by schrodinger what is life
and you know he comes up with some ideas
and he even mentions you know molecular
basis that you know was wrong it was a
crystal that was aperiodic not a double
helix of nucleotides but uh i wonder if
you could recapitulate a little bit of
your thoughts on on life as information
which which i believe you touched upon
in a previous book um but uh what what
is life to answer uh the uh if you can
answer schrodinger's question left
unanswered in his book
well uh we've gone from god to life so
let's we'll go back to god don't worry i
thought it's a big one
but but the life he is so i read that
book when i was a student and i thought
yeah it does seem uh life does seem
pretty remarkable to a physicist uh i
think i said earlier it's like magic um
but
you know what do we need now his ap
ready crystal uh actually turned out to
be very prescient because although he
didn't say well it's a double helical
structure um he was exactly right that
what life
needs or what genetic information needs
it needs some stability if it's to be
handed on from one generation to the
next shouldn't be thermally disrupted so
it needs to be have the properties
stable property of a crystal
needs to lock in
its structure
but it needs
crystals don't contain any information
they're just periodic structures
and so what you need to encode
information is to have to break the
symmetry as we talked about earlier and
you have um
irregularities of some sort and here and
so the idea of an aperiodic
crystal is exactly it's an information
rich stable molecule it's just what dna
is and because of the four letter
alphabet of dna uh you can encode a
staggering amount of information uh in a
strand of dna but it is it is relatively
stable it's not disrupted by thermal uh
fluctuations uh at room temperature so
that that was uh pretty good but i don't
think he answered the question i think
he hoped that somehow quantum mechanics
would come to the rescue after all
quantum mechanics explains all other
matter but it sort of curiously can't
explain living matter
but
rather more adventurously
and i take this as
the jumping off point for my own recent
interests he said that we must be
prepared to find a new kind of physical
law prevailing in it by it meant living
systems
not just a new physical law not just uh
you know alongside maxwell's equations
and so forth
we've got you know schrodinger's life
equation a new kind of physical law and
as i said earlier i think that
traditional laws of physics are not a
good fit in biology for reasons we could
talk about at length but but one of them
has to do with the
the separation of uh of scales uh by
which we make so much progress in
in most areas of physics take solar
physics for example uh we can talk about
uh turbulence in the um in the
photosphere without worrying about the
nuclear reactions taking place in the in
the core and so forth so we can sort of
separate the scales out very well
with life you can't do that there's top
up and top down and bottom up causation
and it's all a tangled sort of
self-consistent uh mess but to
to actually directly answer your
question what is life i would say
it's a sort of catchphrase but a lot of
people people use that life is chemistry
plus information the essential thing
about life is that the information is
not just any old uh
mishmash of of
bits it's uh it's actually
i can say that again it's not any
mishmash a bit
it's actually information which is uh
organized and which can bring about uh
the
organization of mata in other words it
serves a management role
and so uh we
if you measure information in bits as
shannon taught us uh many decades ago it
doesn't somehow capture uh the
contextual nature of biological
information
so
for example if we talking about dna
take a gene
what is a gene well it's um
a gene is
a set of instructions for ribosome to
make a protein for example
but you can't tell by looking at a
particular sequence of dna whether it's
instructional information or just junk
you just shuffle the bits you couldn't
tell it's only in the context of the
system as a whole
that you can tell that that information
is instructional
uh that it is functional and so uh we
can't
you see this is what i say earlier
that's the the scales you can't
decompose it in the same way that we
like to in physics it's a systemic
property so we need information which is
um
uh which is potent only in the context
of the system as a whole and there has
to be a molecular milieu that can
interpret those instructions and act on
it so we're into this sort of
dodgy area like you know semantic
information and meaning and so on that
the
instructions in dna have to mean
something to the organism and
philosophers jump on you to say well you
can't use terms like meaning and so you
sort of slide around with the
terminology but there's no getting away
from it that we're dealing in living
systems with not just shannon bits
but with something that goes beyond that
that we have not yet properly captured i
don't think yeah
and of course that does evoke uh
concepts of creation and the ultimate
teleological entity uh and all
uh knowing i'm the present uh omniscient
omnipotent creator and i do want to
pivot there to uh to
questions of theology you've been on
unbelievable and you've had debates with
uh with
uh with
the believers and and non-believers i
want to ask you because it's not exactly
clear it's sort of a little bit
ambiguous or has been to me
where do you come down i mean is that a
proper question first of all i've i've
heard people like you know jordan
peterson and others say things like you
know how can you say believe in god you
know and it's better to say does god
believe in me is that even a meaningful
question first of all for me to even ask
you
uh well i'm asked that all the time and
my answer is well i'm not a
conventionally religious person uh
that's number one and number two is that
as a scientist i don't have to uh uh say
well this is the way it is and i'm not
going to change my mind and so i'm
interested in the issues and the
concepts
that you can't work in areas like
cosmology where you ask questions like
what happened before the big bang
what is the nature of time and then you
go to quantum physics what's the nature
of reality and then you go to life what
is life and then what is consciousness
you know all those things
which i love to think about you can't
think about those without coming up
against those same age-old questions
that for centuries were part of religion
and so i naturally find myself talking
to those people they seem interested in
what i have to say
but my advice is always this for anyone
uh listening to these words
that
in my view it's perfectly okay to be a
scientist and think well what what does
my scientific work suggest about
and i've got to use the dreaded m word
again meaning or purpose in the universe
if anything you know because it's just
there is or there isn't um
that you you can arrive at a conclusion
well there's something going on or as i
prefer to say there is a
a rational scheme of things uh that
science is uh busy uh unraveling that
the universe is uh um is not just
uh hodgepodge of odds and ends it is a
coherent uh scheme that we can come to
understand and i think that's deeply
significant so you you through your
science you can arrive at a position and
if that happens to concur with some
particular religious point of view well
then that's of some interest but what
you absolutely don't do is decide in
advance what you want to believe i think
there's a god that did this and that and
shoehorn the scientific facts to fit and
i'm afraid there's far too many people
in that latter category they've already
made up their minds that they believe in
a particular type of god
and uh
the worst example is of course um the
so-called god of the gaps so if uh if
somebody is convinced uh that there is a
god and god created life
and they'll turn around and they say
well you scientists can't explain the
origin of life so therefore we need god
i mean that's that's an appalling line
of reasoning so
first of all i haven't really got a
fixed position on these things secondly
i'm not conventionally religious i don't
go to church or anything of that sort
and
but i you know i like to talk
to theologians some of them are very
smart you see some some
if you think about 500 years the
greatest intellectuals were actually you
know theologians and mathematicians
and these people
dealt with these really tough topics
like if there is a god is god within
time or outside of time and can
something come from nothing
and you know why does mathematics work
and how you know they thought very
carefully about those things
and i have found uh found that you know
entertaining and sometimes productive to
revisit some of those old arguments i'm
particularly interested in one that
theologians don't want to talk about
anymore
which is
the concept of a necessary being you
know we're we're all engaged in trying
to explain the universe and then
religious people say well it all goes
down to god and then you say well how do
you explain god well god doesn't need an
explanation well that's no good but then
they turn it around and say what do you
think and i think well the laws of
physics seem to do a nice job or where
do they come from
what's the origin of those and i say oh
well most scientists don't like asking
that question they they just sort of
accept it as given and they say well
point made you know we we both have a
what i sometimes call a levitating super
turtle that holds the tower of turtles
up and the question is whether you call
it guard laws or physics or something
else we haven't invented yet um is it
the case that we could uh that we could
be sure of something absolutely that
there is something uh that would form
the bedrock on which the rest of our
explanatory scheme would rest and the
concept of a necessary being
came out of monotheism
as a notion that god's non-existence
would be logically impossible but that
is a necessary being is a being uh that
that cannot not exist um and is it
possible to make that argument and uh
people tried to do that and as i say
very few field agents these days will
want to dabble around in that they'd
regard it as a
for theology but i think it's you know
really important whether it's science or
theology or any ultimate explanations
is it going to be an infinite regress an
infinite tower of turtles or can we
somehow
come up with a conceptual scheme that
gives us great confidence for that we
can build upon now this necessary being
if such a thing is coherent concept is
does doesn't necessarily bear any
relation at all to traditional gods
and and i don't really have uh very much
time for traditional notions of deities
it doesn't appeal to me very much but i
do think um the way i prefer to put it
is that uh
that the existence of a universe that
uh complex self complexifies that brings
forth
uh life and brings forth beings like
ourselves who can not only observe the
universe but comprehend it
in some deep mathematical sense
i think is tremendously significant and
so i think we are there is a scheme of
things
and
we humble human beings are not the
pinnacle of creation or anything but
we're embedded in this scheme of things
in in a manner that our science
manifests
that embedding it's through for me
through science and mathematics that i
feel i'm part of this this bigger scheme
it's a long way from traditional
religion but then i think we need to get
away from traditional religion you need
to go beyond traditional religion it's
fine if it gives people comfort and
fulfills a social function but it's an
explanation for the physical world uh
it's well passes used by date so so
that's really my position i'm expressing
it pretty bluntly but that's the way i
feel no i think that's wonderful and
actually that you are willing to grapple
with it is in concert with the greatest
you know minds of of history including
you know paul dirac and stephen hawking
both of whose gravestones you show
rather macabre in this halloween season
you show both of their tombstones yeah i
was waiting for boltzmann's tombstone to
make an appearance but dirac of course
said god is a mathematician of a very
high order and he used advanced
mathematics in constructing the universe
albert einstein once remarked what
interests me is whether god had any
choice in the creation of the world and
stephen hawking said if we do discover a
theory of everything it would be the
ultimate triumph of human reason for
then we would truly know the mind of god
the god equation
um of course at least one of those you
know is essentially a militant or at
least a self-declared atheist stephen
hawking
of course as ambiguous uh whether or not
albert einstein and paul dirac were
actually uh you know
theologically inclined um but this
brings us to the final topic which has
to do before we get into my patented
existential questions which i will
remind folks that you need to subscribe
to my to my mailing list to get the
answers to paul's responses to my
thrilling three existential questions
that i'll be asking in just a minute but
before we get there i want to ask if
your thoughts on the multiverse have
evolved and you famously said um
invoking an infinity of unseen universes
in other words the multiverse to explain
the unusual features of the one we do
see is just as ad hoc is invoking an
unseen creator the multiverse theory may
be dressed up in scientific language but
in essence it requires the same leap of
faith and i use that in a prager
university video that i shared with you
once um but i want to ask you those you
know hawking and and uh clearly was not
literally taking seriously the notion of
god's existence and the mind of god uh
it's ambiguous again uh leonard miladno
was on the podcast uh last year and said
you know that was basically to not turn
off you know ninety percent of the
possible leadership uh who do believe in
god and his ex-wife uh et cetera et
cetera einstein as i said was you know
said as many kind of atheistic uh allied
statements as
pro theistic statements if you will and
dirac as i said never once really
mentioned it besides god in that one
sentence about mathematics um are you
using creator here are using god here
and the notion of god as a as sort of a
bromide or to chastise the kind of
uh approach of modern physicists
including your former colleague there
lawrence krauss who was on the show not
too long ago um you know that they
invoke this multiverse and it's
tantamount to god without you obviously
believing and describing in a specific
instantiation of god in other words is
this more of a commentary on on
physicists willingness
to
accept potentially unfalsifiable notions
or is it uh something else and have your
feelings evolved since that article in
the times a couple of uh maybe 10 years
ago
i don't think my feelings have evolved
i do believe that to be a scientist you
have to have uh accept as an act of
faith i mean you've got to believe that
the universe is ordered in a rational
manner and furthermore it's intelligible
at least in part to us because it would
be a fruitless exercise it was all too
baffling you wouldn't bother to do it um
and so uh
that's the sort of founding
um
faith that you you need to to start
doing science and so the question is uh
is that
somehow uh you know just as bad if you
like or just as as much a leap of faith
as people who say well i believe in a
rational god who created it all
um and because as i indicated earlier
i'm interested in those sorts of
concepts and
and as a matter of fact i have come up
with a research project that if anyone
listening
to this uh is interested in doing this
uh then
there may even be a source of funding
and it's the following that people
banded these words around
like um
my uh my tower of turtles is better than
your tarot turtles because it's simpler
that sort of thing
and there's a famous argument that
richard dawkins had with
richard swinburn the theologian
that what's the point of invoking a god
to explain the universe we might just as
well accept the universe and swinburne's
answer was it simpler to expect to
accept an omnipotent god who then
created the universe as a simple
explanation uh to which uh richard
replied if i remember correctly um
well uh the creator would have to be at
least as
complex as the system it created
and so words like simplicity and
complexity get banded around and the
question is what is a simple explanation
and we're back to occam's razor well
there's a whole branch of mathematics
called algorithmic information theory
which in part was invented to quantify
uh the
simplicity of the complexity of
explanations of the world
and if you believe in occam's razor then
you would believe that we should opt for
the one that is simplest and so the
simplicity item is a good one if you
think oh yes a single super being is a
simpler thing to believe in that
than uh
infinitive universes
most of which are unseen um you know
then you can make that argument but the
point is we can actually quantify this
you could take
um
in in principle anyway you could take
your favorite model of god you know this
god has following properties
you could quantify you could work out
the algorithmic complexity of this god
and then you could put that alongside
this is my favorite multiverse model and
compare it with the algorithmic
complexity of that and and i bet you
that mostly they come out about the same
that in other words it's an awful lot of
things you have to sort of take on board
and i don't think um
at the moment we've got the right
conceptual framework for being able to
say
ah this explains all of existence
because this is also obviously simple
in a measurable way much simpler than
the others so i you know i think it's an
open
question that could be
uh literally investigated in a
quantitative way as to you know who who
which is the greater leap of faith
an unseen uh uncreated uncles agent
uh with the power to create a universe
or an infinite number of universes so
they both
there's both an awful lot of uh
information
that uh that has to go into that uh so
so that's that interests me so i uh
and i'm open i often say two cheers for
the multiverse because the reason it's
so appealing
to so many of my colleagues is it
explains the weird bio friendliness of
the universe it does look like often
called the anthropic principle it looks
like the universe is rigged in favor of
life there are many examples i won't go
through them but
the feeling is well
this looks too much like design but if
you have an infinite number of universes
then some of them will get it right and
it's a selection effect the only one uh
it's no surprise we live in a universe
that's bio-friendly because we couldn't
live in one that's sterile
and so it sort of gets around that which
is is better in my view than just saying
uh well god did it um and so i say two
cheers somebody verse but then people go
on and say well that's all you need that
explains all of existence
uh because he doesn't because when
you've got a multiverse it needs his own
laws and usually the laws are involved
quantum mechanics and gravitation and
all those things in the multiverse where
they come from right so you're really
pushing the problem up a level so it's
it's sort of an improvement on just sort
of declaring there was a god that's one
universe but i think uh it's it it it's
a mirage to suppose it's explained
everything
right as a as a you know as an
explanatory feature to explain what we
do observe to to actually posit that we
have to wait you know perhaps billions
of years for our universe to eat another
universe um as as you depict
the cover and the famous uh the famous
uh cold spot and the axis of evil and
all sorts of other anomalies that we've
been discussing and we could go on for
hours and hours more but i want to be
respectful of your time and uh and and
you've been so gracious i would like to
wrap up
with the uh thrilling three
questions that i ask all my beloved
guests who come on the show and two of
these involve your future one your
immediate future or perhaps not
immediate but
at age 120
and then the next one goes out a billion
years and then we're going to go and
actually go back to your past so i'm
going to start if you will
with a question that i ask which has to
do with what form of wisdom what value
system what articulation would you like
to provide for future generations uh
biological and ideological if you will
as an inheritance a sort of ethical will
that would be coming into effect when
you reach the biblical age of 120
hopefully in many many years from now so
paul what ethical or wisdom teaching not
material
inheritance would you leave but what
ethical or wisdom
advice would you leave as an inheritance
to the millions of people who look up to
you for for wisdom and advice
well i'm going to say something
which doesn't seem very profound
but it's actually very important and i
think we all learnt it during the
pandemic
that we have to be nice to one another
and i've
through my life
i was born just after world war ii and
the horrors of nazi germany and then the
horrors of the soviet union and in china
the uh
the um
great leap forward the great leap
forward and it's greatly backward and
all of those things and then uh you know
for a decade or two it looked like the
world really was moving into the sunny
uplands and that we were the democracy
was spreading and that uh
um
it's impressed by stephen pinker's uh
book that you know we're actually
getting less violent less wars and all
the rest of it
and now just in the last few years it
all seems to be going backwards and i
and i
i really and this side this homily
we've got to be nice to one another
it served us very well so my wife and i
um found ourselves in a somewhat happy
situation we were in uh sydney we went
for a week for spring break and we
stayed a year because of the lockdown
and the the travel ban and uh and there
was so little coverage in australia it
was a good place to be um but you know
if ever we would uh squabble about
something uh you know who's gonna wash
the dishes uh i would always say
you know we're in a lockdown we've got
to be nice to one another that's really
important and
and you know a lot of a lot of what has
happened i just heard about it today a
lot of domestic violence sort of come
during the pandemic and so on stems from
the fact that people have forgotten how
important it is
that if you're you're living together
with someone and it applies in
households it applies in countries it
applies globally uh you really have to
go out of your way uh to be nice to the
other side and when we see uh
the sort of you know the sabre rattling
and the tit-for-tat uh violence and all
of these things
um it's such a basic human instinct you
may not agree with somebody else you may
have grievances against them
but
um
at the end of the day we you know we're
on one planet and we have to learn to
live together now you touched upon
another topic which is
i think about a lot and we actually have
a meeting coming up at arizona state
university on this very topic which is
that in the age of ai
uh we're going to try to embed human
values
into our
artificial intelligent descendants and
it's a real problem
that how we embed those
human values in perpetuity
because these ais will be generating the
designing the next generation of allies
and the next generation are making them
um is there any way we can enshrine
fundamental principles of decency uh
that will uh perpetuate it indefinitely
i don't know how to do that
as the most famous laws of robotics you
know we're at attempt to to state that
but how do we actually do that or will
these ais develop their own system of
values that could be uh very different
from from ours um so uh
talking about the age of 120 i think
we're already
gonna we're hitting that problem now and
if i were to lead to 120 i think it
would become a really major issue
now i'm not sure how wise that is it's
sort of common sense isn't it really
rather rather than anything terribly
profound
uh about uh human nature uh which is
obviously deeply flawed the the the
other point i would like to make uh an
answer that it's to echo
uh eo wilson who said uh that we have um
uh
paleolithic emotions and we have
medieval institutions and we have 21st
century technology
and that's a dangerous mix now we can't
change our human nature
much
and we
technology will be what it will be we
can change our institutions
it seems to me they're not well suited
for many of the problems we confront and
so we we used to look up to things like
you know the united nations or elected
governments or the world health
organization or
you know the large banks that was sort
of oiling the wheels of the system we've
lost faith in a lot of those
institutions and the church you know has
been very solid by
uh sexual abuse and uh
and celebrities seem to always be
you know we can't really look up to
celebrities whether sports celebrities
or
film stars anymore because they they
seem to uh for always be getting
themselves into trouble um you know what
are the institutions that we can build
that can cope with this with this next
challenge
we need new ideas and we need them now
yeah i agree and and science used to
fill that role and it's dismaying to see
science become politicized and then used
and as a cudgel uh to force the certain
aspects of
state-sponsored uh agendas but uh for
good and for bad um that has uh has been
a little dismaying because it used to be
science was apolitical i always say um i
love astronomy because there are no you
know democratic comets and republican
asteroids or things like that but you
know nowadays there is a
there is an undergirding of politics in
almost everything and that leads to
polarization not of the cmb type that i
like but of the political type next
question takes us a little further into
the future and you may remember uh
fellow countryman uh sir arthur c clarke
and his uh and his movie or his book the
sentinel that became the movie 2001 the
space odyssey where these monoliths
when they're floating around in space
sometimes and first they're encountered
on the plains of the african savannah
and we're not really sure what they are
maybe they're time capsules maybe
they're not and i wanted to ask you if
you had a time capsule a monolith that
would last for a billion years uh
lurking in our solar system uh perhaps
uh what would you put on it or in it
that would encapsulate uh not just your
career but but the pinnacle of what
human beings have achieved not unlike
richard feynman's famous cataclysm uh
uh question um so what would you put on
a billion-year-lasting time capsule to
kind of swagger and show the uh the
great heights that humanity has achieved
well it's no surprise that i would pick
something from the world of theoretical
physics because that's what i i think is
such an achievement
not just because we're good at it and
we've explained so many things but
because he does touch on what we were
talking about earlier that you know is
there something like meaning or purpose
in the universe and i said well that
there is a coherent rational scheme of
things that we tap into
uh i another way i like to put it is
that there's
like a cosmic code or a hidden and
encrypted subtext in nature which we
call the mathematical laws of physics
which you have to work hard to uncover
so i think that our
enterprise in uncovering that deeper
layer of reality
is what is finest about
humanity now of course some people will
object and they'll say but you know
great works of music or arts
surely are more significant and i'm not
decrying those it's just that if we're
leaving a time capsule for an alien mind
the question is
what would it mean uh it always seemed
to me that
if we're to communicate with the aliens
there'd be no point in sending them the
latest football scores or the outcome of
somebody or others election or anything
like that
it would mean nothing and be of no
interest anyway
but if we were to send
the fine structure constant in binary uh
they would know we'd attain a certain
level of understanding of uh
quantum mechanics and
uh electromagnetism and so on so it
would convey an awful lot so it depends
where this time capsule is supposed to
represent the finest achievements of
humanity
uh
which
would mean nothing to an alien mind or
whether we're trying to really
communicate
uh look we got this far
this is something you can surely
understand and that's right and that's
where we got to
very nice and the final question in the
troika of questions has to do with the
far
distant past if you will and that
harkens back to our namesake arthur c
clarke's famous uh third law
that
the only way to discover the limits of
the possible is to venture beyond them
into the impossible so i want to ask you
paul uh what advice would you give to
your former self a 20 year old paul
cetera what would you give advice-wise
to give him the courage to go as you've
gone into the impossible
that's an excellent question and i often
think about this
i often
in my mind you know send a little
message back in time to that uh
you know poor bewildered you know
frightened child trying to make sense of
the world and the world is is
frightening to a child and um
and
when i embarked on a scientific career
it was a huge risk
my family
i i was the first in our family even the
extended family until uncles on ever to
go to university
so that in itself was a big departure
but becoming a scientist a physicist you
know i don't think there was anyone in
my family knew what physics was
um and so
really this was a very lonely venture
and i thought well is this foolhardy uh
am i going into something that would
lead nowhere and my parents are very
anxious that i should uh you know quit
the university and go work for a large
company that will provide me with a
decent pension
and and for them uh stability was the
important thing the idea that you would
uh
my father worked in the same job for 40
years
the idea that you'd switch jobs switch
careers which countries you know was
completely outside their
uh experience and so i was doing
something which looked a bit scary and
which didn't have a lot of support a lot
of encouragement
and i suppose i would say to my young
self
will be adventurous b-ball because i you
know there were a few times when i
thought
well i you know this is
going to lead nowhere but i didn't know
what else to do
and so i sort of hung in there and by
good luck
um we talked about it good fortune i
picked the right topics i picked the
right places to work the right
colleagues and i soldiered up
but it was a worrying i think all young
people i mean it's not just when you're
a child the universe is scary but people
embarking on their early career you know
their phd postdoc that sort of phase
will they ever settle down or can they
buy a house have a family
those sorts of things very daunting
and so to my younger self i would say
well don't be too you know just stick to
your guns
it'll all come right in the end but of
course for many of my colleagues it
didn't come right in the end they quit
and they went into other other fields
but i think they've all done very well
tim bunch we're just talking about
earlier the bunch davies vacuum and tim
uh after his phd i think he did one
postdoc and then he he left the field
and went into the financial services
sector lost touch with him these days
i'm sure he's made a good good career
it's creating virtual money out of the
vacuum
well i hope he sends you a bunch of
money paul because
you deserve it um it's been such an
honor talking with you as it always is
that you're so gracious
all the time as we get together uh you
are a cosmic
mensch if the multiverse exists i only
hope it does so there'll be plenty of
you to go around
paul davies congratulations on this
phenomenal book what's eating the
universe and other cosmic questions a
delightful delicious uh treat for the
mind and soul i should say as well paul
thank you so much for joining us on into
the impossible well brian thank you and
for your huge interest and support for
my endeavors
any sufficiently advanced technology
is indistinguishable from magic
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign